foreign
ER welcome it's so wonderful to have you
here today thank you for joining us
we're going to be talking about your
directorial feature debut in her hands I
can't wait to hear all about that
process of making such a beautiful film
but before we start can you tell us a
little bit about what it was like when
you were younger in Afghanistan what it
was like growing up
thank you so much it's lovely to be here
with you uh some of the good memories I
have from my childhood is being able to
play soccer on the street with boys with
my friends and also I used to have a
bike I used to go out every evening
with my friends
to bring groceries to just go you know
spend some time together and just be
there and exist
and that very active life has continued
for you I know that you started making
films at a really young age when you
were still in high school is that right
uh yes I was in 11th grade when I
started I was part of a program called
citizen journalism and documentary
filmmaking and I was representing my
hometown uh Mazar north of Afghanistan
as that's how I started making films and
it was uh we were supposed to make one
documentary one short documentary per
month from pre-production to
post-production and we were very excited
about it and it opened other doors I was
able to go to the places I have never
been and I was able to meet people
communicate listen to them and try to
tell their stories
let's talk a little bit about in her
hands can you summarize a little bit
about what the film is about and and why
you chose to tell that story uh the film
is about a strong woman who was trying
to make a change in her community
and like many other Afghans from my
generation zarifa rafari was trying to
make a change in her own hometown of my
Don chart my donor back and she was
quite famous in Afghanistan so I was
really curious to know about her more so
that's how I visit her and then we were
trying to make a film not about only
about who zarifa was but also the
country itself so we try to include
other characters to be able to tell a
story of the country not only one person
and the journey of the country towards
2021
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
struggle outside of me
so you will ask him
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the film spans appeared I think you
started working on the project in 2020
and zarifa the main character is the
youngest female mayor in Afghanistan in
the capital city of a province that has
always had a strong Taliban presence and
you did go out and and you filmed in the
mountains with the Taliban
you said earlier that one of your
favorite parts of of filmmaking is
talking with people and telling their
stories it must have been difficult
meeting people whose views you don't
share tell us a little bit about how you
managed to build those relationships and
and how how you were able to film there
um I think filmmaking and the
storytelling is more about listening to
people understanding them no matter how
different they are so this is how when
we when we started working on this
documentary in her hands that's how it
started so with zarifa for me it was
easier because she was a woman she was
from my own generation and we were
trying to make a change in our
communities and using different tools or
different ways but then also we thought
it's important to include also the
Taliban because that was peace talks
going on between the U.S government and
the Taliban but other ones were not
included and we as African women knew
that we will be more affected than
anyone if there is any change in the
country especially if Taliban will come
back to Power when you met with
some of the senior leadership in the
region of the Taliban
how did they respond to you were you
able to
have conversations and and did their
opinion of you do you think change over
the course of the filming
uh when I first started contacting the
Taliban so basically we did it through
the leadership we contacted them to be
able to go there and film them it took
us some time they did not respond to
messages on time so it took us weeks and
months to be to take permission but then
once I was there because I was a woman
and then after they said after 25 or
more years there was an Afghan filmmaker
a woman on the mountains with them so
they were quite shocked to see me there
so when I was doing the first interview
they tried to not look at me but then I
Remember by the time they started you
know being more comfortable and then at
the end I remember when I was saying
goodbye to the one of the leaders one of
the commanders he was blushing and he
wanted to shake hands with me and then
that time I wasn't sure I was like what
will happen because I see all these
other Taliban commanders and Taliban
soldiers and they had their guns with
them so I was like What if I shake hands
and something happens to me and I
remember our local producer who visited
Taliban so many times before he kept
saying that another be careful don't do
that so yeah
and did you shake his hand
um he didn't want to do that at the end
so yeah we left it there yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
with the same people who were sending
written death threats to zarifa the main
character in the film as early as 2017.
tell us a bit about the the risks that
both she and you faced working in a
province that had such a strong Taliban
presence
it just came back I I can still feel it
um
it was not an easy experience uh because
you know that any moment you might get
cult
and there were times when we filmed that
night days and nights and I don't know I
was with her and there was fighting
going on between Afghan Army and the
Taliban and also whenever we were on the
car I remember she was she used to hold
my hand really tight saying that
tabanova if there is a sticky bomb in
this side of the car or that side of the
car
but you know when you're going through
so many crises you find ways to deal
with it
and then we try to remember the good
things about you know being there and
then I was I used to say that zarifa we
are very close to couple it happened
most of the time on the way between my
Don vardak and Cobalt
or I I remember when we were in the city
and we lost a few friends in Taliban
sticky bombs exclusions and we were down
most of the time but it doesn't mean
that there was no life we found ways to
deal with it we found ways to be happy
with our own ways to find Solutions at
least to raise our voice I remember we
did campaigns we did protests to
make people our leaders and the world
leaders listen to what was happening and
what was waiting for us in the future
but unfortunately I think
um
we ended up where none of us were ready
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
you spoke about how many women in
Afghanistan were actively campaigning
to
continue to move forward and not to fall
back into old ways as the filming
progressed and you realized that the
Taliban were gaining
power and and more likely to come back
to a position of strength how did that
feel for you and zarifa
did it change when you were
in villages in cities could you tell
there was something different in the air
I would have thought I was in a cabal I
was not able to see the change
because everything was okay everything
was all right but whenever I went to The
Villages
to other provinces and I remember coming
back I came with a lot of information
but I was not really able to live in my
own family I didn't want my sisters to
be scared of their future I didn't want
my mother to be scared of her future and
my future and if I have told them that
okay I saw that these things were
happening in the provinces especially
meeting Taliban I knew that they were
progressing and I remember whenever I
went to other provinces in the past I
wasn't really sure about it but I it was
eye-opening to see all you know
the Taliban people like me
ordinary Afghans all of us we were
trying to build a country
in our own ways but ended up destroying
the whole country
um and yeah
the flags changed
when we crossed from one territory to
another territory there was a republic
flag and then there was Taliban flag so
we knew that there's a difference and I
remember zarifa and I and other friends
female friends we talked about it
a lot uh we were like we need to push
for it we need to do something to change
uh we knew we had the fair in our heart
that Taliban might come back but we
thought they would be part of the
government
uh and the way it happened when the
government collapsed it was not only the
government it was
the people with
full of hopes and dreams and the future
collapsed in front of us and we couldn't
do anything about it we did have fair
but we didn't know that it will end up
the way it did hmm and eventually it it
got so bad that zarifa had to leave she
she left she came back she had to leave
again you have had to leave and it's
something that very few people have to
make those difficult decisions it must
have taken a lot
do you do you plan to go back if you can
would you return
um
after Toronto for one week my heart was
really calm and I was thinking about it
because since I left Afghanistan the
fire was there you know
and when I left I left my soul in
Afghanistan with my loved ones with my
country
with my homeland with everything I had
and built for all these years
um the way we left we we didn't know
that it will happen and I remember when
I left I did not say bye to my loved
ones I still remember
my family I still remember my friends
I told them that you know this is not a
goodbye I cannot say goodbye you don't
know what will happen I will come back
maybe I will go to the airport I don't
know it will happen or not I will be
back and I was making excuses because I
didn't want to leave my country that was
home that was everything
um yeah
I kept my passport
um but yeah that's what it keeps me
alive
and people might have different dreams
some people might think that okay I want
to travel I want to make the best fun I
want to do this and that but my biggest
dream is to go back to Afghanistan and
live the way I used to live
we all hope that that will happen sooner
rather than later but for now we know
that the situation is very difficult for
for many women
you've you came to Europe
um and even here we've spoken about the
everyday sexism that you experience and
how exhausting it is to educate men on
issues around gender equality
um
are there parallels do you see any
opportunities for us to learn from each
other because I know many people in the
audience will feel your pain and
recognize that exhaustion
how do we learn from each other how do
we work together as women globally
to create change
sexism is everywhere and we need to come
together to work on it
but the only thing I would say that it's
tiring and exhausting but we should not
give up
we cannot stop so we need to have
solidarity
to work on it together to push for it
and hearing stories like yours like
zarifa there's an amazing line in the
documentary where
we follow her in such
extraordinarily difficult circumstances
and she's constantly under threat
and she says well men have had 40 50
years to get this right and they haven't
yet done it right so I'm not going to
give up is that representative of the
spirit of many women that you
encountered in Afghanistan a spirit of
almost all the women I know in my
country including my grandmother my
mother my friends
all of us
because yeah what is ugly and then it
was the man who created the war it was
the man who made peace we always pushed
for it but then there was no space for
us on the table no matter how hard we
pushed for it but it doesn't mean that
we give up and it's done
and we are you know we made peace with
that
um it was desperate of the whole country
it still is and it is the woman who are
resistance in Afghanistan today
uh they were protesting a solidarity
with Iranian women and COBOL in front of
Iranian embassy
uh so yeah I think the future is a
female
it's as
and we are the ones who can make change
because we don't fight
we don't care about ego we care about
Solutions
to all of the people listening today
inspired by Your Story by the strength
of women Afghanistan
what can we do to support the struggle
you said solidarity is key to change and
I couldn't agree more
how do we work together what can we do
to keep
the the plight of women in Afghanistan
in the news and to make sure that one
day you're able to return and do the
wonderful work that you've been doing
um I think women in Afghanistan need
solidarity more than anything right now
I remember I was interviewing a woman
who were protesting because I was
working on a research for Amnesty
International and whenever we talked I
was asking them why they started
protesting and they said that tabano we
lost everything we had
we are not able to work we are not able
to go out without a maharam a man family
member and we are not able to uh move
freely trouble to other provinces to
countries outside Afghanistan without a
man so it means that uh Taliban do not
count women as humans or equal to men so
there should be a man to validate that
they exist
and they say that we lost everything we
had and that's why we are fighting we
are not afraid to die uh but it makes us
happy
and encourages when we see women no
matter
from outside the country uh supporting
us
and that's all we need and they were
thanking me all the time for doing the
interviews and they were like you listen
to us and it's important for us
so there is a need to come together and
support the woman in Afghanistan in Iran
or any part of the world
because all we fight for is our basic
human rights
I think it's really important to support
a woman in Afghanistan or any part of
the any other part of the world who are
fighting for their basic rights it's
2022.
I know that woman we as women we are
political our bodies are political our
opinions whatever we say whatever we do
is political women get criticized more
than
men are no matter in which field and
it's really important for all of us no
matter where in the world to support
those women protesting on the streets in
Kabul and other provinces of Afghanistan
and one of the ways we can do this we
can open a conversation about
Afghanistan so it's on the news again so
people talk about it and we don't forget
what's happening there I know that I was
the lucky one who is here now who is
able to work but I also know that it was
painful to leave
um
uh but for them because they are
fighting they need our support
solidarity and we need to put pressure
on our governments
no matter where in the world uh to
change the policies to put pressure on
the Taliban uh to change their policies
and make a change
I think people can start by watching in
her hands it really is
A Beautiful film it's incredibly
compelling
and for me I found there was threads of
Hope in there
um so
um I think watching the film
understanding this Incredible strength
of the women of Afghanistan will inspire
many many people and hopefully they will
step up and show that solidarity
um and continue to to raise awareness of
the issue
you no doubt will continue to do so I
know you have more films I think that
you're hoping to make in the future
um and we're just very very lucky to
have you as such a wonderful and
compelling storyteller
shine a light on this issue and an
educate us all so that we can stand in
solidarity so thank you it's been
wonderful listening to you today thank
you to Mana thank you